[Music]
so I'm a developer advocate here at
Google normally I do crazy live demos
but unfortunately you won't see that
today instead I want to go through some
really cool features that we have at gke
that I think a lot of people you know in
the documentation gets lost somewhere
and they just don't know it's available
so before I get started I do want to
know that there let you know that
there's a Dory available Dory is how we
ask questions internally at Google
during presentations and so you can go
on your app and do that Dory queuing
anything and you can ask questions by
just typing them in so gke or google
kubernetes Anja how much people are
familiar with this most people yep
so gke is basically Google's managed
kubernetes offering what is Cooper nice
engine basically it's a one-click
solution that lets you deploy your
master and your notes create those
permissions those for you and give you
access to them right and so you can
access that master it's kind of hidden
away from you
you don't have to worry about it we take
care of upgrading it and patching it and
doing all that good stuff and at Google
of course we've been doing containers
for a really long time most of you
probably seen a slide similar to this we
launched cgroups an open-source it way
back in 2006 kubernetes was open sourced
in 2014 and then gke went go generally
available 1.0 in 2015 but so what
everyone is doing kubernetes now right
everyone all the cloud providers have
kubernetes random mom-and-pop down the
street has kubernetes as long as you
pass the conformance tests you have a
kubernetes right so what so what why is
Google different I really think that
there's fundamental things that need to
be done around kubernetes to make it
useful right just having kubernetes by
itself it's great but it can be a lot
harder to use than it needs to be and so
there's three major major areas where I
think you need support around an a
platform that's built around kubernetes
to really to really make a good big
difference right so one is
infrastructure then we have networking
and security and tooling and automation
so let's talk about infrastructure to
start so these are things we take for
granted every day
so cluster creation yeah it's literally
just one command and you get your master
and your notes right g-cloud contain our
clusters create give it a name and boom
you're off to the races other people
might make this a little harder if
you're doing it yourself you know how
hard it is sometimes to set up
kubernetes manually which gke one
command and we're good to go pretty
straightforward stuff everyone here
should know this but just you know cuz
things something to remember about we
take for granted every day
speaking of nodes that are automatically
created they're actually automatically
updated and repaired so a lot of
providers might update their master
version automatically but then leave
node management to you we kind of
believe that the whole thing needs to
work together and so we actually
automatically can update and repair your
notes so if you go from 1.1 12 to 13 we
can actually as your master version gets
updated we can update your node version
for you automatically and if something
goes wrong with the node let's say the
docker demon dies the cubelet something
goes wrong with it
we can do that we can automatically
detect that with the health check delete
that node and spit up a new one
automatically take it to place again you
don't have to do anything you don't have
to worry about natural infrastructure
anymore so another really cool feature
of GCE is node customization so you can
make something called custom VMs with a
custom amount of CPU memory you throw on
local SSDs GPUs things like that and you
get all that same capabilities in gke
what this means is you're not limited to
certain types of machines that can run
on GE any GCE VM can also run on gke ROM
and this gives you a lot more
flexibility if you need a beefy node to
do some sort of workload and need really
small node to do something else you can
have that mix-and-match of of
capabilities if you need GPUs like a P
100 or a V 100 or whatever easy to add
on to your gke cluster I'm speaking of
of picking the right size
GCE actually has a machine learning
algorithm built in to do something
called cluster node right sizing
recommendations so here we can actually
look at your utilization of your VMs and
say hey you're over utilizing your VM
you should probably pump pump up the the
ram a little bit so you can get some
more
smoother performance or this machine is
way too big you're wasting money
downsize it save a bunch of money on
your bill and again because it's built
on GCE all these features pipe directly
into gke now one of my favorite favorite
things is preemptable nodes and I don't
think people use these nearly enough to
take advantage of them so I actually did
a three month data collection experiment
where I ran an app that was constantly
paying and I wrote a bunch of data and I
did a bunch of data analysis and I found
out that you can basically run three
times your capacity for the same cost
and get almost no like no detectable
baseline like difference right so if you
had one node for ten dollars and you had
three nodes now for ten dollars yes
those preemptable nodes can die they get
preempted every 24 hours
they might get shut down but it happens
at such a regular basis and it happens
and kubernetes is so resilient on
spinning up the container to take it to
place that if you're running stateless
workloads and you're not using
preemptable VMS you are definitely
leaving money on the table I have a
whole blog post about this where I go
into detail ooh and emissions so of
course I talked about how you can kind
of mix and match those different types
of VMs together and so the way we do
that in gke something called node tools
and so again something that I don't
think people taking that advantage of
most people make a kubernetes cluster
and to have one type of node you can
actually take different types of nodes
give them different labels and tags and
then run different workloads on those so
your database can go on a more CPU heavy
memory heavy node your stateless web app
can go on the smaller nodes that are
cheaper your machine learning workloads
can go on your GPU nodes and you can
have them all in the same cluster which
makes networking and all that kind of
stuff a lot easier to set up and and
another big feature that we rolled out
about last year is regional clusters so
by default clusters are created in a
single zone right the problem with that
is there's twofold one if that zone goes
down well then you're out of luck and
two during a master upgrade the cluster
might still work but the API server goes
down right so you can give it updates
and things like that with a regional
cluster we actually spread those nodes
over three different zones in the same
region and so this gives you one
higher availability right if a zone goes
down you're still good you still have
those two other zones that are up and
running and to higher master
availability because you have highly
available masters because we have three
different masters one in zone once we
did when we do an upgrade we actually do
it one at a time so you never lose
access to your kubernetes api server
really cool stuff and if you're using
regional clusters you can use regional
persistent disks now these are really
really cool so basically it creates two
disks and one is a clone of the other
and any right that's sent to the first
disk is just fourth at our network level
to both disks at the same time so any or
any rights that go in are actually
written to both disk simultaneously with
no performance downgrade right and so
what happens if zone a goes down zone B
becomes hot and starts serving data and
there's no real disruption to the end
application this is actually how cloud
sequel for Postgres runs under the
covers it uses these regional persistent
disks to provide high availability and
because gke has native built-in
connections to all of the stuff you can
use it as well in GAE now another
important thing is auto scaling and so
everyone can do auto scaling based on
CPU pretty trivial but with stackdriver
and with gke you can auto scale on
custom metrics so anything your app
needs like number of incoming requests
or a number of open file handlers
whatever you need to scale your app you
can send that to stack driver and scale
your gke nodes based on those metrics
and speaking of auto scaling gke provide
something called vertical pod auto
scaling now how many people are familiar
with horizontal pod auto scaling most
people so for example auto scaling is
pretty straightforward you run out of
CPU you spit up another pod you spend up
another pod it spins out horizontally
but vertically scaling can actually set
your memory requests per container and
actually make them go bigger or smaller
depending on the workload so we actually
again use machine learning to figure out
how much memory your container needs so
if it needs more will actually make
redeploy those pods with more requests
and if they need nuts we'll spin them
down with less we're actually spinning
that the the pod requests up and down
for you automatically so we can do both
vertical pod hollow scaling horizontal
auto-scaling as well as cluster
auto-scaling so it's like multiple
dimensions of auto-scaling all at once
and we optimize that all for you which
is really cool look at that and of
course today we announced anthos gk on
prem so we can do all this really cool
cheeky stuff or most of it not only on
our cloud but on Prem and in other
providers as well so that's really cool
and this other talks that can go more
into detail on that so talk about the
infrastructure and now I want to really
get into the bread and butter of where I
think GCP shines into except surely in
terms of GK eat so when you go from a
monolith or a VM based architecture a
lot of the networking assumptions you
make change dramatically when you move
to containers and micro-services right
the networking gets way more complex and
if you're not built from the ground up
to support that kind of stuff things can
fall apart right the old paradigms kind
of fall apart so let's talk about
networking first so normally you have
your nodes and you have pods on those
nodes and so these nodes our VMs and
they have IP addresses on the VPC right
but those pods the IP addresses that
they have are virtual IP s that are only
routable within the cluster so the
problem here is that when you want to
send a request out those IP aigis up I P
addresses guess get masked with NAT and
so if the node IP address goes out not
the actual pot so you don't really know
which pod on that node is making that
request and the same thing coming in you
don't it's really hard to route traffic
to a pod on the node because you have to
go through the node first but with IP
aliasing or V PC native pot I piece
those pots actually get real GCP IP
addresses that are natively routable on
the V PC so what does it let you do it
lets you do really cool things like
container native blood balancing so in
the old world you spit up a load
balancer that load balancer has no idea
what's running inside of those VMs right
it just no send traffic to that pot to
that VM on this port and then IP tables
inside of that node has to do another
routing to the actual pod right and that
pod might not even be running on the
same VM we call this a double hop
problem so it might go to one
one virtual machine and then get routed
to another virtual machine and then go
to the pod right a lot of hops a lot of
latency that's added to your
infrastructure with container native
load balancing our load balancers
actually know the physical IP addresses
well not physical there everything's
virtual these days but the actual IP
address up the pod itself and can route
traffic directly into that pod without
going through IP tables without going
through netting without any of that
stuff so you get a lot less than the
agency and more importantly you get more
transparency you don't have to go
through your logs if you go to your VP
see flow logs and like okay well I went
from this VM to that VM and then to that
container instead it says from that load
balancer that container straight line
right much easier to reason with and
debug and analyze and speaking of load
balancing we have internal load
balancing as well and so this again a
bit straitly it's straight built into
kubernetes so we can provision an
internal load balancer the same way as
an external load balancer and so this
lets you expose your kubernetes services
to non kubernetes services inside the GK
inside Google Cloud right so if you have
a service running on VMs a traditional
kind of thing that you haven't migrated
to gke yet you can just expose your gke
service and it gives you an IP address
that's routable inside of the V PC and
the really nice thing is because this is
done with an SDN there's no overhead and
everything is just done just a box
sitting there right we just know where
to send the traffic and the other way
around cloud mat so if you have a third
party service that requires a whitelist
of IPs well it's kind of hard to do with
gke those nodes come and go the IP
address has changed you might spin up
your cluster to make it bigger or
smaller so how do you give them a
whitelist of my peas well with cloud NAT
you can actually create an IP address
and all the traffic gets routed through
that IP address so it looks like all the
traffic's coming from a single IP
address but it's scalable because again
were you doing Sdn magic under the
covers to make it look like the traffic
is coming from this IP so you just give
that IP to your third party a person
they whitelist it and you're good to go
you don't have to worry about managing a
list of IPs and things like that and
then we have a multi cluster ingress so
this is really cool you have a bunch of
clusters around the world
you can spin up a single load balancer
with a single IP address and they can
route traffic to all your clusters
automatically right so we actually find
the closest cluster to the user using
anycast and we can route their traffic
to that cluster without you having to do
dns or anything complicated and actually
have a talk a few years ago at next
where I spun up a multi cluster ingress
using queue Federation which is quite a
while ago so if you want to check that
out check it out and then we have deep
integration with other networking
products like CD and IP and cloud armor
so cloud CDN as the name implies is our
CDN really powerful stuff I a P that
identity we're a proxy lets you throw
this little proxy and friend of our load
balancer that we call it beyond Corp you
can read the paper basically like you
don't have to build security if you if
you if your application requires
something like a VPN to connect to it
right if using VPN for security this is
an alternative where you don't have to
use a VPN instead you can use OAuth to
authenticate you as an end user and then
login to that service so for your
application still looks like it's in the
VPN but this proxy kind of lets you do
that without VPNs which is really nice
and then cloud armor which is our anti
DDoS protection and these are not just
built like add-ons these are you can
actually configure all these things with
kubernetes native objects which is
really cool all right
so security security is really important
especially on cameras land how many
people saw that the Tesla like crypto
mining thing yeah so they're they're
cluster got hacked and people started
running crypto stuff on it and so what
I'm gonna talk about now is kind of
layers of security that we add to make
it more harder for an attacker to get
into your systems right so the first
thing is private clusters and master
master authorized networks private
clusters it's literally what the name
implies the cluster doesn't have public
IP s therefore it's only internal right
and again master authorized networks
only certain people can log into the
master not some random person on the
internet cannot like association to your
master right so again just another layer
of protection so if they break into your
network then yeah they still could log
into your master so how do we get around
that so we have something called network
policy network policy
gke is we automatically install
something called calico into your
cluster to make sure that when you set
these centric policies that are enforced
and so these are really powerful stuff
you can say you know this namespace can
talk to this namespace but not the other
way around or these pods can talk to
these pods but they can't talk to any
other pods and so my coworker ahmet has
a really good blog post and a github
repo that goes through all these
namespace sorry these network policies
and how they work
highly recommend checking out I stole
this picture from but it gives you again
another layer of control right so
someone is able to break into the app
web they can talk to as any containers
but the containers can't talk back right
so you got a little bit more control
over what's going on kubernetes secrets
so for the longest time kubernetes
secrets were not encrypted in more
recent versions of kubernetes they are
encrypted and with gke
you can actually encrypt them with cloud
KMS and so you can manage those
encryption keys and rotate them and do
everything that you can cloud kms but
now for your kubernetes native secrets
again just making it easier to use right
and then binary authorization this is a
really cool new feature basically let's
say someone does break into your
kubernetes cluster and now they want to
run crypto mine dot latest or something
like that well they can't because it's
not authorized so we can actually
enforced sign container so only
containers that are signed by you can
actually even run on your cluster right
so again rogue developer who wants to
run something can't do it it has to be
signed so this is really powerful again
locking down another layer of security
that we give you in gke now how many
people know about this container
registry vulnerability scanning few
people yeah so this is really cool if
you're using alpine or Ubuntu it
actually automatically scans your
containers from known CVEs
and a surface those for you so you can
see I upload some really old containers
and they have tons of issues as expected
and you can go through and see like
what's important to you what you should
update and things like that usually if
you're building containers fairly and
regularly they should be fairly
up-to-date but this is a good way to see
like oh I have an old container with a
bunch of under abilities let me update
it
or hey this new burner nobley came out
let me make sure that I'm not being
affected right so really cool stuff
again built straight into GCR so the
last section monitoring and tools these
are things again I think people forget
about or just kind of hey it's there I
don't remember but when you don't have
it you're like I really wish I did
so one is stack Erica Mary's monitoring
there are quite a few tools nowadays to
monitor kubernetes stack remember has
been updated to monitor not just the VMS
that are running your your cluster but
actually your pods and your services
that are internally right so here we can
see it you can't see anything because
that's like a super blurry picture but
if you could see that picture you would
actually see the nodes the pods in those
nodes how much memory they have they're
healthy all the custom metrics that you
sent all in one pane of glass which is
really nice
see I CD as necessary cloud bill is one
way of doing that and I think cloud
build is a really easy lightweight CI CD
tool um that you can use especially for
if you don't have anything so you
complicated you just put your steps in
it runs those commands and can build
your container for you you can do more
pop complicated stuff like actually
deploy the kubernetes we're on to health
checks do all this kind of stuff it's a
very very simplistic product but it
really has a lot of power and because
it's completely serverless you don't
have to worry about provisioning a CI CD
like build pipeline or anything like
that you literally just run up job and
it just runs it for you and you get tons
of free build minutes per day which is
really cool now this one is something
that most people again don't really
think is a differentiator
but the gke dashboard is really powerful
you can see your workload you can see
your services you can drill it really
deep into these things with a really
nice QE you can edit them right from
there you can create new deployments you
can look at the status you can do all
this kind of stuff again without writing
a single line of code or going into
single command line right right from
that Pantheon dashboard you can see
everything that you need which is really
nice the service broker this one is
really useful if you want your
kubernetes operators to be able to
provision other
GCP services or for that matter open
source services or even other cloud
services directly from gke objects right
so you can say hey spin up a cloud fire
store database and it'll just spin that
up for you and give you this credentials
back as native gke secrets really really
powerful and it gives you a better
integration into the rest of both Google
cloud and the open source ecosystem and
finally I'm gonna talk about namespace
and label resource usage so how many
people here I have a GK cluster is
shared between teams few people so
really cool thing is you can actually
export usage based on namespaces and
based on labels so let's say that you
have namespace X that's used by team one
you can actually see how much of the
cluster that they use versus namespace Z
and the same for your apps so if you
have two apps labeled app a and they're
in different namespaces you can again
get that export of the resource usage
for those apps outside of the place so
really cool stuff especially if you have
multiple teams using the same cluster
and you want to break that down for
analytics purposes so we have two
add-ons that I want to talk about
because I think they're really powerful
so one is the gke sto add-on you click
one button when you're creating a
cluster and you get sto installed into
your cluster for you automatically
really cool stuff if you don't know what
sto is I'm sure there's some talks
around here that you could probably
wander into but long story short is
called the service mesh and it really
adds a lot of value to if you're doing
micro services architecture on gke it
adds a lot of value for you
automatically without you having to do
too much work if you don't know what SEO
is go look it up it's pretty cool and
then we have cloud run on gke as well
and so this built on top of ISTE O&K
native to be able to run serverless
workloads on top of gke so it's the same
cloud run api's that you can run server
lessly on on GCP you can actually run it
inside of your kubernetes cluster as
well so you get the same developer
experience and to end no matter if
you're running on our server let's
platform or on our kubernetes platform
but don't take my word for it uh with me
I have bread from Symphony Symphony
Communications he's a VP of architecture
here and
want to give him the floor to kind of
talk about his GK experience and here
you go
yeah thanks in deep and so you know as
many of you we kind of embarked on the
kubernetes path a while ago looking at
the ability to containerize an
application the application of course
has been around for longer than what we
actually wanted to do with
containerization we were doing a lot of
the heavy lifting that Sandeep described
you know we were running virtual
machines we were maintaining those
virtual machines operating systems up
and trying to keep a secure platform
what Symphony actually is is it's a
secure team collaboration platform but
it is really focused on financial
services customers as our primary
business segment and if you've ever
worked with those customers you know
that there are extremely sensitive to
security so security was always kind of
at the core of everything we do and you
know we've worked for a couple years now
with the gka team specifically around
kind of crafting the security messages
that you heard from Sandy working with
product managers telling them what was
important for us and our customer base
so that it becomes more accessible
across the entire industry not just
something that you can actually you know
focus on from an internet-based
application but actually something that
the individual banks and large financial
services institutions would start to
trust as well and that's really again
what symphony is and where we see a lot
of value and a lot of continued
innovation and in trying to drive that
security things like the private gke
clusters the ability to actually know
that you know banks still think about
how we're gonna actually get into our
networks make sure that everything is
signed signed images are going to be
very important from our perspective as
well so that we can actually have high
confidence that the cluster is only
running what we want it to run and the
individual teams within both our
organization and our customers
organizations have good visibility and
good auditability around what that's
running and where where those individual
pieces are able to talk to each other
cool so Brad I asked them some canned
questions for you and then we'll open up
the floor to questions from the audience
and again remembered that Dory is
available if you want to just type it in
if you don't want to come up to the mic
so when you chose GE as your platform
and what was like one of the biggest
challenges moving from of the again you
said like a VM based architecture to the
container based architecture sure so we
actually are dual hosted you know we've
been hosted in AWS and GCP for a long
time we had been on both in the VM world
and but we treated our VMs very much
like you would consider a an internal
data center and in fact part of our
architecture does include our customers
data centers as well that's one of the
reasons that we can actually have the
security model that we have so we've um
we've always been looking at ways to
optimize the efficiencies around how do
we administer AWS GCP and our customers
data centers and that's really where
kubernetes and containerization shines
it gives us the ability to package our
application in ways that we can deliver
to our customers on-premise there they
do it in gk on prem in some cases but
they do it in cloud foundry or other
things that are container based
orchestration systems we build our
containers for our cloud system to
really kind of evolve the the platform
there it was some heavy lifting I mean
you know many of you have probably been
through it you know the assumptions
around VM some of the things Cindy party
mentioned they have to be rethought and
the architecture has to be evolved yes
oh speaking of architecting so has
kubernetes in gke kind of forced you to
react attack or reconsider some design
decisions that you've made in the past
it is but I mean you know part of it as
you mentioned monolith earlier and our
original application like most as you
know early startups get started tends to
be a little bit monolithic and so that's
really what we're looking at right now
is how do we break the monolith in such
a way to gain resiliency gain scale at
the right layers that make sense allow
teams to operate because we have you
know 150 300 engine you know 150 300 new
years depending on how you count the
external help that we have that are
driving in parallel and as you guys know
you know trying to get everybody Alliant
ain't everybody head in the same
direction it's really difficult and
microservices can make a big difference
there
we are still breaking apart the monolith
to some extent but but that's for the
evolution path that many of you were on
and that's we're on as well it's what we
say the biggest challenge in breaking
our decomposing let's say that it's a
nice word
posing your monolith right so it's a
it's a really long journey as you as you
mentioned what's gonna been the the
hardest part and then how is GK you can
I helped you do that sure yeah
so I mean the nice thing about GK is the
ease of access that you know Sandeep
already mentioned you don't spin up a
cluster with one command we've had kind
of our engineers that we've been
training you know Google actually offers
a bunch of training support to our Tam's
have come in and brought in individuals
to show us and our teams how to use
kubernetes the right way best practices
way so we can actually evolve the
thinking the hardest part from from in
my opinion of how they do this is rarely
the technical part the technical part
you know a couple people can sit around
a whiteboard and and break up the thing
and decide the right way to break it up
the right contracts to make sure the
servicers talk to each other but you
know if the if the engineering team if
the talent that you have don't
understand the tools well enough or
don't understand that the methodologies
you're trying to achieve that's where
you can get a lot of advantage just by
the accessibility of gke there's no
reason that we should have to spin our
own kubernetes cluster to learn
kubernetes with GAE
okay so final question now what two
questions in one
what what's the most like exciting thing
about GK for you or the future of GK
like what's the most exciting thing that
you see on the roadmap that that you're
excited about maybe that's public but
and then more personally what do you
guys are building inside symphony that
you really want to talk about and are
super excited about well I can't talk
too much about the latter one you know
again we might ride you know we are
doing a bunch of things around workflow
automation you know you you see these
things happening you see autonomous
agents happening in the in the industry
you know we we are a tool very similar
to slack or Microsoft teams although
we're focused much more on the security
in the compliance aspects but all those
same things that you see happening on
those tools you know even things like
chat ops that you guys are probably
already doing in your teams are just as
relevant for our customers and our
financial services industry and so we
really see a lot of value about you know
bringing containerization to those tools
that our customers are building as well
and one of the pieces you know you
ga-eun Prem one of the pieces that is
still difficult for us and our customers
is that on Prem piece we'll never get
rid of it it's part of our architecture
it's a key part of our architecture we
also won't be administering our on on
Prem clusters because there are
customers data centers but they may opt
to use more and more of GK on Prem to
really kind of aid themselves in being
making that an easier tool for them to
use but our customers are also like I
said very security conscious and so you
know we have to understand that some of
the kind of cloud managed on Prem
infrastructure for them is something
that they have to kind of work through
and understand the security implications
of they're really uncomfortable with
things reaching from the cloud back in
you know they have very constricted
firewalls and you know border security
in a lot of their data centers so it's
something to consider and you know as as
gk evolves certainly there's there's
kind of an air gap notion of potentially
how we might view and administer a
cluster without actually having direct
access to
[Music]